i have a feeling that uh what's  happening to him is that  he's um  kind of because he was transitioning as  a player from his youth um he was  slowing down  uh slowing down more and more and more  in his career  and now it's going backwards he  he's speeding up  he's like so he was getting slower and  slower slower until at some point he  reached a slow peak of slowness he was a  slow player at some point with time  troubles and then it went the other way  he became faster faster faster and now  he's super fast again he's like he's  playing like  i mean i never played with yang vishi  but something like hyanni pogba is what  he plays like and he plays just very  fast and relies on calculation on prep  and um yeah it's it's a way to play just  to play very quickly and it's one of the  more unpleasant styles to face  and  well the games that i saw of him is just  he's just playing very very fast